welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today and
tomorrow obviously one of the biggest
stories even bigger than the indictments
recently handed out by the special
prosecutor's office is the tragedy that
took place in parkland Florida this past
week Donald Trump could not have botched
the response to this massacre any worse
than he actually did not only did the
man go down there and give a speech
where he didn't once mention the word
gun but he also posed for one of the
most idiotic photo shoots I think I have
ever seen any sitting president in my
lifetime perform sitting there with
first responders thumbs up big giant
smile on his face like he just won a
medal of honor 17 people most of them
children dead and Donald Trump sat there
smiling like an idiot as if he had done
anything to make it better anything to
help or as if this was some kind of
joyous occasion and then I mean I wish
that is as bad as his response got but
oh no it got so much worse
he then goes on Twitter decides to blame
Obama for this Democrats had the White
House and full control of both the House
and Senate for what two years and they
didn't do anything about gun control now
I hate to admit it I I have to agree
with him on that that's correct they did
nothing about it they should have but
they didn't they did during Obama's time
in office put in protections that made
it a little bit more harder for mentally
ill American citizens to buy weapons to
buy firearms which Donald Trump repealed
in his second month in office last year
but then after trying to pin this as an
Obama failure Obama screwed up Obama
Obama Obama every
bad that happens in the world in the
eyes of Donald Trump and Republicans so
he's going to go back to Obama so then
after that Donald Trump says yeah we got
a mental health issue problem in this
country we got to fix it that's that's
the real issue okay well again you
literally made it worse and you're not
taking any responsibility for that you
can whine and cry all day you all day
long that we have a mental health crisis
but at the end of the day you're the one
that repealed that rule that wasn't Paul
Ryan that wasn't Mitch McConnell that
wasn't the Koch brothers that was you
you signed your name on that Donald this
Massacre is 100% yours you own it you
helped this happen and when the next one
happens and it will it could be today it
could be tomorrow it could be by the end
of the week but it'll happen again
because they're not doing anything about
it again wish that was the end of it but
it's not Donald Trump after all of this
decides as he usually does he's gonna go
play golf Donald Trump spent part of his
time on Saturday morning golfing while
just a few miles away family members and
fellow students were lowering their
friends their children their brothers
their sisters into the ground as a
result of this massacre and Donald Trump
was out golfing and then later that
night Donald Trump finally decides to
talk to a few people about gun control
but it wasn't the victims families it
wasn't their friends it wasn't experts
it wasn't advocates it was the wealthy
members of mar-a-lago according to
stories to reports what's going on right
now
Saturday evening Donald Trump at
mar-a-lago in South Florida was asking
his wealthy donors wealthy buddies the
people who had to pay a $200,000 entry
Phee to get into mar-a-lago as members
he asked them what he should do about
gun control in the United States should
we do anything what how do we handle
this I don't know I'm not qualified to
hold this position as president of the
United States so why don't you tell me
mr. hedge fund manager mr. real estate
developer I'm sure you know more about
the issue than I do and I'm honestly
sure they probably do I'm sure that
pretty much anybody in this country
knows more about any issue better than
you mr. Trump and yeah people are angry
I'm angry you know a few weeks ago
there's a Thursday evening three weeks
ago I believe my wife who is a teacher
special education teacher mind you got a
call from her principal saying that a
student has made a threat against the
school that he was going to come in on
Friday and shoot students and teachers
anybody wearing blue that day was his
specific target they weren't close in
the school the threat had been made via
snapchat police were investigating there
will be an increased police presence at
the school on Friday at every entrance
every exit and patrolling the halls I
think they had about eight or nine
different police vehicles parked outside
all day long and that's what she went to
sleep to on that Thursday evening
knowing that she was going to work
tomorrow and a student had threatened to
come in and shoot everyone so Friday
morning she gets up terrified kisses the
kids goodbye a little bit longer than
usual game extra hug not knowing if she
was coming home that day I didn't know
if she'd come home that day she did know
event took place before school began
they found the kid he was arrested
crisis averted
that's not what happened in Parkland
that's not what happened at too many of
these schools or churches or nightclubs
or malls kids went to school that day it
didn't come home ever
and Trump was golfing while their bodies
were being put into the ground